it was a good night for this guy and
deservedly so
Bob Lee Bob Lee won for outstanding
studio host you jerk Bob joins us now
Bob congratulations thank you Dan and
clearly as I'm from Jersey I was able to
manipulate these proceedings a lot more
efficiently than your attempts at
legerdemain there did you win the
electoral vote and I won the popular
vote Bob very possible but I've got mr.
Cohen working on that legal question
right now Michael Cohen is working with
you good okay very mama with his friend
Bloody Mary did you guys have a post
party I think there was one but at my
advanced age I just retreated quietly to
the hotel I did get a text from my
executive producer at 4:43 a.m. which
had me he swears he was getting up this
morning and that is the story and he's
sticking to it so I I will choose to
believe him today where is the Sports
Emmy right now mom
actually my coordinating producer Dave
sárosi did me a huge solid because he
lives here in the city and he had his
car parked last night there so and it
comes in a huge box and so he was kind
enough he'll drive it up and I'll get my
my hands back on it on Thursday is this
the first time you won studio host oh
yeah first time I've been nominated yeah
it's really neat but yeah but you know
you know I rent there Ernie Johnson last
night as I was making my way out and I
didn't see we have a list I didn't see I
assume you're there I was there if you
went to the bar I was there I had my
head down
that's right yeah yeah I had my head
down but exactly but you know and for
those at home with Ernie Johnson that
last night was something so EJ because
he was up there presenting an award or
recognition introducing the high school
senior to receives a $10,000 scholarship
for his work in sports and then Ernie
and as a so EJ so lovely had the young
man remain on the stage and it was
succeeding three or four turning was
scheduled to do which was three
presentations and I ran in there Ernie
afterwards
we just had a quick conversation and
he'd spend time on our show when his
book had come out last year and Andy and
I think we're talking about the same
thing and I had this conversation years
ago years ago with Bob Costas just to be
in the conversation that people think
highly of your work picking among you no
one among the people that you know you'd
like to think are doing the better work
that's that's nice to be in that
conversation it's it's it's a crapshoot
anything I meant what I said lies by the
beat to be mentioned in the same breath
with the guys I was nominated with just
all gentlemen this year it was quite an
honor
Ernie Johnson should win a Sports Emmy
for being the best sports guy in our
business they should have a category
that cuz Ernie I mean I tell people
Ernie is so good at what he does but
he's even better as a person and it's
not that he asked for it so what he did
last night is as you said I mean it's
just so Ernie Johnson I of course was
gonna have the kid up there to accept
the award with me I was gonna go a
little bit further than Ernie Johnson
but I didn't win I I didn't I didn't win
so I didn't get that opportunity so you
stole that opportunity from that little
boy from Miller's II yeah it's totally
totally in character for you though am i
say did you ever have your doubts about
ESPN like did went early stages or even
you know with your core or latter part
of these my gosh in the in the early 80s
we were I think the technical financial
term that I learned in college is we
were hemorrhaging money by the bushel
with early 80s you know if there was a
line send it out at the Xerox machine
getting our resumes ready I mean until
until in the early 80s ABC exercised its
option and brought the total interest I
mean there were questions about whether
Ted Turner was going to acquire us just
for the for the hardware and and shudder
the thing so the yeah the first three to
four years there were no guarantees I
mean there are no guarantees at all in
life and in this business but the early
stretch yeah before you had joined us
you know what really solidified is you
know it was 87 getting the NFL contract
you know the year next year in a major
league baseball contract but in the
early 80s
was touch-and-go and we knew it we know
it there you've seen everything though
at the mothership because you were
basically there you and Chris and Tommy
when there open the door but the state
of journalism now in what we do how we
do it as opposed to if if you do five or
10 years or 15 years previously where
are we headed in in this world we live
in I kind of addressed that last night I
mean our company has a incredible
commitment to journalism a story that
one for the dictator seen last night the
Syrian national football team Assad's
team I mean that was shot by a team of
producers and reporters across the world
for eight months in six different
countries of reporting from Africa and
what that it it is increasingly I think
rare because of the expense involved to
find that sort of commitment across the
board in electronic and in digital
journalism and as I alluded to when I
actually I didn't look to what I said it
lies about my remarks I mean this is an
interconnected interval an increasingly
complicated sports world with rights
fees and partnerships and leagues and
networks and it demands scrutiny and
requires scrutiny on all the parties I
mean the interesting stories how various
leagues do their business how MLB is
trying to speed up the game how the
National Football League is dealing with
the anthem issue and player social
activism what's going on in the NBA on
that issue and you know it crosses over
between business partners and that's a
delicate area as I said I pray that that
worked in that area continues and we'll
see I mean that everyone is is committed
to it verbally but it comes to as we say
in soccer you get to a 50/50 ball on a
story on a whether it's the big picture
or a small edit in the story and that's
that's when you find out talking to Bob
Costas who stole the Sports Emmy from me
last night I'm Bob Lee I should say and
that's a habit it's usually every year
I'm saying Bob Costas so you know what
you're in great you're in great company
Bob you know but hey you raised my game
when I first got there and and hopefully
I
told you that I've expressed that and I
meant what I said last night it was
awesome in the note I sent and I was
really happy for you because sometimes
you can get lost in the shuffle there
and you don't have a hot take or catch
phrases or anything but you just you did
it and you do it every single day so
well done maybe take the next year off
that'd be kind of nice or more than that
I don't know at my advanced age it might
be time to go fishing but and by the way
I'm glad last year the Super Bowl is you
and I had a chance to break bread
together that wasn't been together in a
while and I think fondly of those eleven
o'clock shows when the producer would
come on at 11:02 in our ear and say
you're killing me we were over time we
had an hour and somehow we were heavy on
time and we were two minutes in when we
did the 11 o'clock SportsCenter and
we're like and artwork we have attention
to detail I'd like to think you have
more attention to detail than I do but
we were pretty good with you know how
much time we were spending leading into
a story or doing highlights or a
scoreboard and all of a sudden the
producer did you ever have a moment
where you just lost it because that's
not really in your character you know
out of the building it's it's part of
your character with a great sense of
humor but what about on did you ever
have one of those moments where you just
said I I got no shot here ah oh yeah I
don't think they've made their way on
the air but there have been a few
pencils but tossed and and expletives
undeleted yeah just you blow off steam
I mean it's because she cares so much
but did you ever laugh I'm like you know
like Charley Steiner would always start
laughing yeah
I mean the two of us together yep yes oh
yeah without a doubt
I mean in Spanish diners are walking
chuckle fester self oh you know he one
time said to me we were getting ready to
come out of break and we were running a
tape that had the potential of Mike
Charlie laughs and he was you know you
remember how close we would sit signed
by each on that SportsCenter set it's
almost shoulder-to-shoulder separated by
three feet and 20 seconds back from
break Charlie says I'm going to get
through the stories don't make me laugh
don't look at me said okay Charlie
that's five four three and it's Charlie
story coming out of break
to another camera three just slowly out
of range of the camera but fully within
ranges of Charlie's peripheral vision
pivoted slowly in my chair so I was
staring directly you have no chance go
right over the edge
[Laughter]
East it's not even the challenge to make
you know it was it that was too easy way
too easy
hey congrats well-deserved and and
thanks for joining us hi buddy
that's a bubbly outside the lines for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]